think pika semi-conscious t llego
ishtiaq doctor this is the sound of
Slovakia as performed by Qatar Zia whose
real name is Katerina Kobo Shiva the 27
year old singer songwriter is hugely
successful in her home country her
popularity is boosted by the fact that
she sings only in the Slovak language my
brain works better when I tried to make
poetry in Slavic language and also it's
for me it's a part of a heritage our
language which because it's very unique
like it's not used in any other country
and I also very loved it I loved it a
lot speed awesome similar three bags she
has brought out two albums to date both
to great acclaim from the critics nexus
one she put two supreme OMG she has to
go ahead
the sound of Europe concert series
features the best musicians from each
country the group cello mania are also
representing Slovakia and so is Ludmila
stefani cova a jazz vibraphone player
who lives in Paris four years ago a
magazine in her homeland voted her the
most successful slovak living abroad
the performances are held at the german
finance ministry and include discussions
presided over by wolfgang schauble and
chaired by DWS director-general Pater
limbic deserve answers I really miss
concert series is designed to show the
richness of European culture to show
that when more than just a set of
numbers money or problems and it
actually reminded me of jean monnet one
of the founding fathers of the European
Union who said that if he had to start
over again he'd begin with culture and
the arts Michel palco plays an old
Slavic instrument called the Foo yarra a
1.7 meter flute that was traditionally
played by shepherds the foyer is
considered by UNESCO as part of the
intangible heritage of humanity
it's very very typical in solar care
played by Ross fook blow blow hot and so
on so on it's interesting because
probably it's come from Romania all
Shepherd culture means OH Lakia comes
from from your mind
sklavin editor Gruber ova is an
international star and slovakia's best
known musician the coloratura soprano is
also known as the slovak nightingale she
grew up under communism and European
unity is very dear to her she'd been
taught that won't believe this immense
candy I'm not into politics at all so
I'm not very well informed but if the
European Union were to fall apart just
because of economic interests because of
accusations that others are doing such
and such or we don't have this or that
then I think it would be time for us to
pull ourselves together and passionately
stand by our European identity don't
dance art that sustained
music is an international language that
brings people together the sound of
Europe celebrates the motto of the
European Union united in diversity